two weeks before Silicon Valley Bank
collapsed the CEO sold 3.6 million
dollars in company shares he knew
something was about to go down and told
no one and two weeks later it happened
March 8 2023 tweets DMS text messages
and emails were flying around the
startup community in America and all
these sort of people were telling each
other one thing get your money out of
Silicon Valley bank and then the very
next morning it happened Silicon Valley
banked the 16th largest bank in America
imploded Financial regulars have closed
Silicon Valley Bank and taken control of
his deposits that FDIC announced Friday
and what is the largest U.S bank failure
since the global financial crisis more
than a decade ago svb the 16th largest
bank in the US at the start of last week
has been operational for 40 years and
was considered a reliable source of
funding for Tech Stardust and Venture
Capital firms and it all collapsed in
less than 48 hours
and with two more recent bank failures
with silvergate bank and synergist Bank
it looks like the U.S banking system is
burning down right in front of our eyes
it looks like this might be the big one
and no one is covering the real reason
why this collapse is happening
[Music]
as you guys can imagine researching
these videos takes me to some pretty
dark corners of the internet that is why
I use this app called Aura to protect
myself Aura is a sponsor of this video
and Aura is this easy to use app that
includes everything you need to stay
safe online it protects you from
financial fraud Identity Theft
Protection it comes with a VPN antivirus
software and even a password manager one
great feature of Aura is that it gives
you near real-time alerts a suspicious
credit inquiries like if someone is
trying to get a loan or a credit card in
your name but my favorite feature of
Aura is that it will constantly watch
out for your email social security
number and passwords getting leaked on
the dark web like this email I got last
month about how my information was
leaked on the dark web multiple times
before Aura I had to pay for a lot of
these Services separately but now all of
this is included in one affordable
subscription the amount of money lost to
digital crime has more than doubled
since 2017 alone so cybercon is no joke
you want to get protected and Aura is so
confident that they even offer a million
dollars in coverage to cover eligible
losses and fees due to identity theft
and they even have a 60-day money-back
guarantee all you got to do is choose a
plan with the link below then set up
your account to activate your protection
and then you'll get notified what any
crucial alerts and if you sign up right
now with the link below at aura.com Jake
Aura will give you a 14 day free trial
and you will be shocked at just how much
of your personal information orifice
exposed in just those two weeks so pause
the video and go to aura.com Jake to get
protected now
[Music]
see when startups get money from funding
they can't just go to normal Banks and
put their money there normal Banks want
real businesses with long stable
transaction histories they don't want
brand new businesses that are constantly
moving millions in and out all the time
and because of that startups had nowhere
to bank and Silicon Valley Bank filled
that void svb was specifically catered
towards the volatile world of tech
startups and it gained them a monopoly
on the space just signed a fast series a
put the money in svb that was the
standard and svb became silicon Valley's
go-to bank so when there was easy money
flying around everywhere during the
pandemic Tech startups were getting
insane amounts of funding and they
deposited all that money into Silicon
Valley Bank svb was suddenly seeing a
lot of money flowing into its accounts
in just one year svb saw a 100 increase
in the amount of money deposited into
its accounts in 2018 svb had 49 billion
dollars in deposits by the end of 2020
that number had doubled to 102 billion
dollars and by 2021 the bank was holding
over 189 billion dollars and with all
that money in the bank SVG he decided it
was time to put that money to work which
is when it decided to buy billions of
dollars worth of Investments with their
customers deposits in their eyes why
wouldn't they cash is trash remember we
gotta invest these deposits this is how
Banks make money but it's a delicate
balance as a bank you have to have
enough cash on hand in case people want
to withdraw money just so there's not a
bank run but svb didn't care about any
of that
[Music]
foreign
bought 117 billion dollars worth of
mortgage-backed Securities and 10-year
treasury buzza had an interest rate of
only around 1.5 percent but in March
2022 the feds started raising interest
rates so the value of the boss svb Bots
started to fall as interest rates Rose
sharply and the bond market cratered in
2022 svb's Bond portfolio took a huge
hit because why would anyone Buy svb's
1.5 bonds when there were five percent
bonds you could buy for example now this
would be final if svb didn't need to
sell those bonds for a loss but as rates
went up the money supply started
shrinking there was no more money flying
around everywhere like crazy so funding
for tech companies started to slow down
too so the startups started withdrawing
their money as economic conditions
soured over the last year with tech
companies particularly affected many of
the bank's customers started drawing on
the deposits svb didn't have enough cash
on hand so I started selling some of his
bonds as Steve losses with more tech
companies needing the money in their
accounts svb was suddenly running out
cash on hand to keep up with the
withdrawals so they had to sell those
1.5 bonds at a loss so on Wednesday
March 8th svb made a startling statement
svb announced that I saw 21 billion
dollars worth of his Securities at
roughly 1.8 billion dollar loss and said
it needed to raise 2.25 billion dollars
to meet clients withdrawal needs and
fund new lending they thought no one
would care it was just a measly 1.8
billion dollar loss they thought they
could easily get the funding to cover it
they were one of the largest banks in
America after all our depositors aren't
going to take their money out they have
nowhere else to go but svb was in for a
rude awakening
Venture Capital firms on both sides of
the Atlantic urged their portfolio
companies to move money out of and
battle the lender Silicon Valley Bank
and that and that's when the bank run
happened suddenly everyone wanted their
money out of svb everyone in the tech
industry was telling their friends and
colleagues to get their money out as
quickly as possible within a day svb
stock had tanked 60 and led to a loss of
more than 80 billion dollars in Bank
shares globally with svb employees
receiving their annual bonuses on Friday
just hours before Regulators seized the
failing Bank
the next day the 16th largest bank in
America was no more all in the span of
48 hours but the real question is why
did svb do something so insanely stupid
every single Banker knows when interest
rates go down to zero they're eventually
going to go back up and when they go
back up your measly 1.5 bonds are gonna
tank it was inevitable and yet svb still
bought the bonds why because they
thought they were Invincible no one was
gonna withdraw their money or else would
these startups go we have a complete
Monopoly over the industry for God's
sake none of these VCS and stars would
be welcomed by normal Banks so there was
no need to worry just like every bank
that collapsed before it svb believed it
was just too big to fail and now that
the positors were screwed
although svb accounts were FDIC insured
FDIC only covers the first 250 000 in a
bank account which is a problem because
all these starters have millions in the
bank from their Venture Capital funding
which is why only 11 of the money
deposited at svb was actually insured
companies such as video game maker
Roblox and streaming the vice maker Roku
said they had hundreds of millions of
dollars in deposits at the bank Roku
said its deposits with svb were largely
uninsured setting insurers down 10 in
extended trading but after a few days of
panic the government stepped in the
government is not saving svb it will
stay collapsed or wound up with
remaining assets disperse the creditors
unless a buyer can bring it back to life
however late on Sunday U.S agencies
extended a guarantee to cover all
deposits at the bank it means customers
at svb will be able to access all their
money on Monday morning or in other
words you're bailing out these rich
Venture capitalists with your tax
dollars array to be honest it would have
been nice to see svb not get bailed out
it's easy to feel bad for these startups
but think about it this wasn't their
money they were losing it was money
given to them by Rich Venture
capitalists to feel their giant Posse
scheme that is Silicon Valley and if you
want to learn how the world really works
and why the elite stay on top like this
click the square on the screen to watch
our full video on it right now click the
square on the screen to watch now
[Music]